[Music]
welcome back we had a freaking wild sick
conversation with just right now while
he was just wowing us by his
entrepreneurship prowess he says all of
his failures are some of our best
achievements uh and stuff like that
but we had to come back like that and go
into part two because there's too much
juice and we're getting too much inspo
so we wanted to share that so everybody
welcome back jaspreet
thank you again for having me you guys
are a lot of fun how come
when you fail five times you don't go i
quit
that's normal people right well they
quit after one yeah they fell once ago
they don't even quit i mean they don't
even fail they they they have the
imagination of failing and they quit
yeah they don't even start well
some of our fails here and some of our
success is here and then just breathes
fails like here
well so you know this is tough though
you know like the finishing ones are
really hard because it's like i have
nothing else i don't have any
investments i'm like dang it there goes
my bank account
i got to figure it out right but for me
in the beginning it was just for fun
like i'm just trying to throw parties
and you know have a good time with my
friends and like my friends who were
dj's like it was just that but i think
as i started to get a little bit older i
was like i have to figure something out
because i don't want to be a doctor i
don't want to be an attorney i don't
want to work a traditional job i knew
that i wanted to
be this thing called an entrepreneur
whatever that thing is
but how do i do it i got to just figure
this thing out and i was just like if i
do this it will happen but then that
thing ended up failing but then just
wanted something else so why did why did
you quit the sock game when you killed
it in the first round you got some socks
left so i did i didn't quit i was i was
actually doing it um and we continued
going um but then
because i got screwed over i was like
man i wish there was something that like
i could go to and learn from so i took
out
my phone and i made this class on
something called udemy called how to
launch a business without getting
screwed over
for seven bucks i was like if you like
it just watch like i wasn't trying to
make money i was like just like to help
somebody who was probably in my shoes so
just like whatever thoughts that i had
and i put it under the alias minority
mindset the whole idea being
i thought i thought differently than the
majority of people because the majority
of people were partying i was hosting
the parties majority people like when i
first saw your page on the explore page
and i just saw like minority mindset i
was like yes this guy thinks minorities
are better than everyone else too
i started
[Laughter]
when i saw a minority mindset i thought
he was just gonna lecture us like an
asian dad
some people say that is what i do
stop spending all your money
be a doctor yeah
or not most famous video
so i did that under the alias minority
minds the whole idea of just thinking
differently and people were like oh do
you have a social media page and i was
like no then i created an instagram page
and i started posting you know random
stuff and they were like oh did you like
because i was like posting like long
captions of like you know you know
here's what you can do if you have this
idea and then people are like can you
please start a blog so we have more
in-depth content because the instagram
is you know it's only this much content
that you can put on it i was like look
man
english is my second language you are
not going to like my writing i can't
even write that coherently properly so
no i can't start a blog but i can talk
so
i can make videos so i started making
these videos as a hobby off of my phone
um about how to launch a business
without getting screwed over some basics
of money management that i knew some
basics of investing and i was this was a
hobby but i was really focusing on the
stock business because that was actually
profitable and i was making money
um but then this youtube channel started
to grow and i was at like 10 grand 10
000 subscribers and i remember a friend
asked me he's like dude how much money
you're making off of youtube
like what are you talking about he's
like your advertisements like what are
you talking about he said you know you
can make money from youtube videos i'm
like dude i have no idea it goes into my
back end he's like this is before there
was any monetization requirements that
you don't need subscribers or views
anybody could monetize anything because
you just hit this button you start
making money in your ads from ads i was
like oh yeah let's hit that so
yeah we should do this let's click that
because for me it was just honestly like
a way for me to talk uh to people about
the things that i enjoy because you talk
to your friends about you know in
entrepreneurship and finance they're
going to get bored they're all losers
yeah yeah
oh this guy again yeah they're all
doctors really you know most of my
friends are doctors and they don't like
hearing about it now they're like dang
it dude like teach me what you know let
me watch the video tired of saving lives
i got all this [ __ ] doctor debt damn
yeah it's crazy and so
that's that was uh how i started making
videos and then the youtube channel
started to grow
and i was like well i'm not very
passionate about socks like i like the
business i like the entrepreneurial side
i like how i can scale it it doesn't
need like my face or me but minority
mindset it's not making as much money
but i like this like i actually like
what i'm doing i actually feel proud of
what i'm doing i feel very happy with
the impact that i'm making even though
we weren't that big and so at around 100
000 subscribers my patent got denied for
the sock company because they were like
it's not original enough and i was like
well okay because
i actually i was working on um trying to
see if i could get some licensing deals
someone was like hey if you get a patent
we'll try to connect you to under armour
and we'll try to get you licensing
because i was good that's the real play
well the patent got denied so that all
went through the window and i was like
do i really want to build a sock company
and that's when minority mindset started
growing and i was like well let me try
minority mindset because i kind of like
this a lot more actually i do like it a
lot more socks are you know just socks
at the end of the day very necessary
they're very necessary
so i started every day i started going
less and less effort on the sock company
eventually shut that down and put all
effort some minority mindset and then
started building other companies like
market briefs which is the main company
that i work on uh and minority mindset
is just you know my personal brand
talking about the things that i wish i
knew
when i was getting started what's what's
market briefs market briefs is a
financial newsletter so like if you want
to i thought there's underwear yeah
although socks it doesn't get wet yeah
so the interesting thing is uh we we
sell underwear you do we do market
briefs we have marketplace so the whole
idea is if you join marketing you have
the market graphs on the under yeah we
do
so
so here's the here's how it works so
marketplace is
think of it i wanted to make financial
education and use more accessible
because you know if you ever turn on
cnbc you don't know what's going on like
it's a bunch of tickers you know it
doesn't make any sense yeah so if you
want to be aware you want to be an
investor where do you go well market
briefs is it easy news that are five
minutes long that you'll break down
everything you need to know from stocks
to real estate to crypto to inflation in
a very easy to understand format so we
have something called the 16 year old
rule if a 16 year old doesn't understand
it is too complex
so that's the newsletter and then
what we do is if you refer people to our
newsletter you can win rewards and we
have different tiers of briefers or
readers so if you refer x number people
you become a golden briefer and we send
you a golden pair of
briefs next tier is blue briefer we send
you a blue pair of briefs and then
signature so yeah we do have underwear
i'm going to link you guys okay i'm
going to get those gold pairs nah yeah
exactly
sign it up right now hey i'm going to
sign up under jk news we want we want a
golden underwear [ __ ] you guys dude i'll
get you guys it's my problem right here
how do they find is it just
marketbriefs.com marketbriefs.com and
what's the other one insider market
insider so that's an app that we created
for the education side if you want to
learn how to be a stock market or a real
estate or a crypto investor you get
weekly coaching sessions you can try it
out for free it's a free 10-day trial to
see if you like it because i hate uh
programs where you pay all this money
and then see if you like it or not try
for free you get 10 days go through the
entire thing if you like it stick with
it it's very affordable uh if you don't
like it no problem
no no cost to you so it's an educational
um
uh if you want to learn how to be a
better investor for
probably should have known that because
i was so deep into luna yeah so so
people
you're gonna use this a lot you invest
in cryptocurrency i do invest in crypto
i invest every day into crypto i buy
bitcoin and ethereum and a couple other
smaller coins
he's a dca dca wow
yeah so i buy it every day right so you
bought it at like 69 grand you also buy
it at 20 grand yeah i think um
i started dollar cost averaging
probably when it after the peak it
started going down 2018. no uh
i think i started dollar cost averaging
crypto 2021
um i don't remember maybe it was around
69 but i was it doesn't matter what the
market's doing i'm buying every day
bitcoin ethereum i think we're going to
go through a lot of turmoil crypto i
think yeah why do you think we can go to
so much turmoil uh well so
we had a big crypto we had an everything
bubble created in 2020 2021 because all
this money was printed by the federal
reserve bank
while no wealth was being created so
just think about this no one's working
nothing's being produced got to be
correct but money is being printed right
and so if you're getting money and you
can go to the store and buy stuff but no
stuff is being made what's gonna happen
you create supply chain issues because
stores are selling everything and they
have nothing left because no one's
producing anything so this started
creating all the issues that we're
seeing now and all this money floating
around that had needed to go somewhere
so started going into speculative places
tech companies crypto crypto exchanges
doge there was just a lot of money out
there people had money
well now that
the fed is realizing that all this money
printing caused inflation now they have
to do the opposite they have to take the
money out of the system they're
literally burning cash
and so that means anything that was a
byproduct of this bubble is going to get
hurt crypto was a huge byproduct of it
and crypto unfortunately i mean
still today uh
price is a huge indicator of of like
people's opinions of crypto when it's up
everyone thinks crypto is the future
when it's down people it's a scam yeah
and so
what you have to know if you actually
want to be a crypto investor you have to
actually believe in the technology the
blockchain what do you think of it and
if you believe
in the long term value a down price is a
better opportunity for you to buy
and so you know that's the first thing
you have to ask yourself if you don't
believe in the blockchain if you think
it's a bunch of crap and it's not going
to be around in 10 years don't buy it
but if you think that blockchain is
going to be a big part of the internet
and our future 10 years from now then
this is something that you can consider
buying
and i do the dollar cost averaging i
just i buy it a little bit every day i
believe it and i lost a lot of money
it hurts my feelings i'm sorry
i'm sorry that's just how it is i bought
bitcoin at 35 grand
and i sold it at 28 they did a good job
yeah me too i did the same thing they're
really good at buy high sell
i'm gonna wait until 30 to buy back in i
appreciate you selling it for a discount
trying to hug people up you know you're
aware of the people dude
is there any hope for my we work
investment
oh man you brought wework no
i just i just watch videos about it and
i'm like so can i ask you like how many
real estate properties do you own now
oh i don't know an exact number but it's
the units uh somewhere in the uh dozens
wow
at uh what point do you start going to
um
groups that are selling like a whole
portfolio
like when you
at some point you know like it's like
just buying one at a time it's kind of
time-consuming i've never bought a
portfolio a lot of times portfolios are
gonna be like single-family homes uh you
can buy apartment complexes if you want
number of units in one place i've never
purchased a portfolio it just depends on
the person like if you want to buy a lot
of homes in a certain area i've seen
them for sale but i've never bought them
i bought apartment complexes but never
uh portfolios what's your niche like
residential residential anything single
family single family or multi mostly in
michigan mostly in michigan is the uh is
the real estate market about to uh
as well you know it's gonna come down to
one thing and everyone wants to know are
we gonna see the real estate market
crash well it just comes down to what
the fed does if they keep raising
interest rates which is what they say
they want to do doesn't necessarily mean
that's what they will do but if they
keep doing that
then yeah we'll probably see real estate
prices come down it's not 2008 because
2008 was the real estate bubble which
then trickled down to everything else
now it's the opposite it's everything
else that can trickle down into real
estate so if people start losing their
jobs because of everything else going on
in the world
well then they're not going to pay their
mortgages and then that can affect the
real estate market so if the fed keeps
raising interest rates i do expect real
estate prices to come down when people
start losing their homes that's the best
time to buy right it is the best time to
buy it
because i'm
a noob you know what i don't know
yeah i want to see blood in the streets
uh and i still won't be able to afford
one but i'll know that's the time to buy
it i'll tell everybody else are you
about to miss a mortgage payment like oh
my god oh man
it's good for you
straight to your neighbor
you mentioned that like uh english isn't
your first language um so when did you
come to the states i was born in america
oh uh i was born in michigan you just
went to the wrong school i went to the
wrong school
mother tongue or whatever fur yeah and
then you learn english on sesame street
or whatever exactly
so we i never saw sesame street we
didn't really have i don't know if you
haven't had vanity or cable like we
didn't my parents didn't even know what
that stuff was because like they would
go to these meetups
and people would talk about barney my
parents had no idea what they were
talking about so i never saw barney and
sesame street and all that my brother
got to see more of it but uh for me i
never really got to see that i was uh
out my it was my parents my grandparents
um and i cuz as soon as i was born my
grandparents moved um with us from
punjab or stay in india so they were
living with us so you know i was i got
to spend a lot of time with them because
my parents were working all the time i
didn't get to see them that much what
was what was so obviously you've done a
[ __ ] ton of things but uh there's this
constant thing that your your dad always
wanted you to be a doctor or die right
um
what was kind of like the moment or the
parental perspective as oh yeah what did
you choose to share with them so when
you felt comfortable about not being a
doctor i didn't really tell them much
actually so there's a couple of scares
that happened because i was hosting this
my event planning company
and i had this really big event we were
doing this like there was this concert
going on we had the official after party
it was a pretty huge event it was in
detroit and um parents showed up no
my dad called me as i'm driving down
there he's like are you hosting some
event
i was like oh my god my heart starts
pounding i was like wait what are you
talking about she's like oh someone was
saying that uh some dustplate is hosting
some event i was like well i don't know
what he's talking about i gotta go study
tonight i i don't know i guess that's
crazy how common is jasper
yeah so it's a common name it's not like
super common but it exists so okay okay
that kind of blew over but that was like
a real big scare and then um
it happened honestly uh he's a
subscriber by the way yeah he might be
now um so i was hosting no actually no
this is the soccer company
they kind of knew i was doing something
but they didn't really know no
um but my parents got a call
from one of their friends
and they were like
i just saw your son on the news and my
parents like oh my god what did he do
now and they're like no no no he has his
business and he's doing really well and
they're like
what are you talking about so they
they're like oh okay okay they hang up
then they come to me they're like what
are you doing
then i had to break it i was like well i
had the sock company blah blah blah and
then there
once they
heard other people talk about how
just doing well yeah the news
it just changed and that was when it
immediately changed that's when they
started supporting me um and it was
even because everything you got caught
on was the sock company
the success the success of yourself very
glad it was then because you're even
successful in getting caught yeah
yeah and i was really scared i was like
oh man because when i told them i did i
told them that i didn't want to be a
doctor which was my junior in high
school when did you actually tell them
that so i told them a junior in high
school so they found out about the
business stuff later on
because i still thought that i was going
to be an attorney and this and that but
my junior year in high school was when i
told them that i didn't want to be a
doctor and all hell broke loose rushed
them huh yeah my um that's the asian
coming up yeah
i was i took the mcat
and then after the mcat i was like
there's no way i can be a doctor like
this is definitely not for me your score
wasn't that good my score was okay i
aced it no i i don't think i i don't
think it did like amazing i didn't do
great but i think i could have
gotten into medical school did you score
in the 30s uh was it during the time is
it still like or 45 or something i don't
remember what i think it was like close
to 30. that's what i remember because i
was remember that was like the the hit
this and you got to get in i remember i
was like oh i'm just like close enough
so
uh
what happened so like uh you took the
mcat and then after you told him i can't
do this he just put a stethoscope on he
listened to his own heart that's stupid
he's like
i'm dead
i want you this is not for me i told him
i didn't i can't do this i'm not gonna
do it and my dad was very angry and my
mom couldn't believe it like my dad was
like very furious did the dining table
survive
i don't know what survived like i had
calls coming from
my family members across the country and
from india saying
why are you disgracing your parents why
are you doing this they long with
are you disgracing your parents i really
love your socks though can you send me
some more yeah you got some more clubs
too
so is that where a compromise happened
where you're like but wait i'm gonna do
law so that was so my mom didn't believe
it she like did not think that i was
telling the truth i was just joking and
i was like dude i'm serious like
uh until like my senior year for like a
year and a half my mom really did not
believe that i was being serious and
that was my parents were like
you have to at least become an attorney
to keep the prize oh they even told you
the bargain bro like the bargaining
power
just be a lawyer you think they had this
like conversation in their bedroom that
shows you it's just like yeah what are
we gonna do with this guy it's like
sucks
no no we gotta at least get him to be an
attorney because his stocking is so
disgusting isn't that a crazy pivot
though because you've been studying your
ass off for the mcat right to go to law
school and now you got to study for the
lsat which is i didn't know what a
prosecutor or a defendant was like i
don't know what which one who who's the
plaintiff i don't know what these things
so i don't know any like when i
i came into law school probably one of
the dumbest people there like when it
came to law because people they're like
oh my father is an attorney this
person's a judge i've been doing this
and i i knew like i didn't even know how
i don't know what a judge was like
you're like i almost got food i saw judy
on tv like is that what it's like like
that's the extent of law that i knew
that's me
settlement i know actually it's funny
because i remember i was i was walking
with my law school friends one day and
what was the word um
acquitted
i i was trying to sound smart right and
so i don't know which one acquitted
words did you get did you get in trouble
did you not get in trouble yeah what
does that mean i know no nickname yeah
i'm curious i'm asking so acquitted
i i don't remember which one it is
but i remember that oj yeah off the hook
just think of the o.j you're off the
hook you're off the hook if the gloves
don't fit yeah so that's not innocent
then no is that it or is that it i use
it in the wrong way and they were like
oh really
someone backed out and i looked it up on
google and i was like yeah by verdict of
not guilty the verb is ojd yeah you're
off the hook
you used it wrong all while you were
already used around walking around with
just like smart law school people and
they were like oh really i didn't know
that this person was acquitted and i was
like oh dang did i say the wrong one i
go and checked it on google i was like
dang i i can't correct this now i'm just
gonna say that i was wrong but yeah i
mean that's like i did literally didn't
know
anything about the legal system how this
stuff worked but it was i enjoyed my
time there like it was fun i learned
uh something i mean that's a lot of
stuff that could help business isn't it
yeah do you think it helps your business
at all now like all your entrepreneurs i
don't do any i do i have attorneys man
and like people that say the same thing
oh you can review contracts there's no
way that i would want to review my own
contracts like i don't trust myself to
review my contracts so like you know
people come to me with legal questions i
refer them like i don't do anything when
i read
how do you even read this [ __ ] man
the the wording on it i'm like what the
[ __ ] is this here and there and there
there there yeah it's like
therefore and thereof on this date of
renewal by acquitted acquitted yeah dude
double jeopardy hurry up there's a lot
of words i'm just like just sign me bro
if we get into a fight let's [ __ ]
know what double jeopardy is i don't
know what double jeopardy is nobody
knows can i tell you something it's the
thing that goes
what's scary about law is like you're in
a situation right and you're like okay
cool here's like some sort of engagement
that i'm gonna be in i need a lawyer to
look over that right yeah so you hire a
lawyer but then the lawyer sends you an
engagement thing yeah and you're like
well who the [ __ ] that's my back where
do i set this thing who's going to read
this the assistant lawyer
let me talk about that for a second
because i agree and that's all right the
traditional law is
such crap and it's not just for the
people but for also the attorneys
because when you get in the higher end
like you want some real business
attorneys like they're gonna charge you
up to like two grand an hour and the
reason why is because you have all these
layers of crap in the system and it's
like oh you got to pay the associate
attorney you got to pay this attorney
it's like the most outdated industry i
hate it yeah the way that the way that
they they're like oh yeah we're going to
be your lawyer and then they really just
get like one of their [ __ ] assistants
and then they still billy it's like 300
at their rate it's like oh i sent this
email cost it took me like 30 minutes so
it's available on 375 an hour so you're
getting chart
i literally looked at [ __ ] and i
remember we spent like 30 grand on a
lawyer to handle something for us and i
swear to god i could have done it myself
it was the biggest [ __ ] waste of
money so that's why i invested in the
company called up council to help break
this traditional
law industry you got answers bro you
just gotta
because i was like you know what am i i
wanna because at first i was like maybe
i could create something but i was like
we and me and a buddy my from law school
he's a good friend of mine he actually
works with me now and the reason why he
became friends is the first day of law
school he asked me he's like just what
kind of law do you want to do
i was like i don't want to be an
attorney he was like me neither so we
became friends because he wanted he was
a business person
we stayed friends throughout law school
um
but him and i were like you know because
we kept talking about this about how
like
old school this whole system was so we
started like talking about what can we
do how do we change the system make it
better for people make it better for
attorneys i've counseled dogs today
you're so [ __ ] good dude look at this
i'm about to sign up for everything yeah
where's your only fans
working on that stuff
maybe you can help create me one
[Music]
you